[Music]
we're in the Royal Palaces of Seville
called darrell of casa which are palaces
built by Peter horrible in the 13th
century it's one of the most visited
monuments in Spain the Alcazar will be
like the water gardens of Dorne
since Dorne is a new world that's just
coming to the show it was introduced in
the fourth season but we didn't really
see it now in the fifth season they will
finally get to see the kingdom of Dorne
we're now driving up to a little village
called Makka morn in which there is a
quarry that's been there for a number of
years now and in season 1 we built the
set of Castle black there because
there's a lake in the quarry within
season 2 we built the battlements of
King's Landing for the Battle of
Blackwater with Stannis's boats
attacking is still standing although
it's it's looking a bit worn these days
now we're driving up to have a look at a
seperate mid-construction of a fishing
village set north of the wall we'll
begin to see how that's taking shape
this morning the fantastic thing about
the Hard homestead is we're building
something that is so far north this time
that what we get to do is create a
fishing village that is exactly as the
name describes its hardhome what we've
been doing both in concepts and in
models is looking at the location out in
macklemore and created what we need for
the action which is a longhouse in which
a lot of action takes place and then we
have the landing area which we're able
to use the lake that exists in mega
maaan and so through having those sort
of necessary requirements we can then
build this sort of tent city that will
be created out there
we've got lena headey and jonathan pryce
today we're shooting a scene here from
Episode three which is what we're
calling the soup kitchen which is a kind
of rundown area of behind the Sept of
Baelor and it's a scene where Sir she's
looking to have a conversation with a
high Sparrow who is a whole new
character we've got a beautiful
courtyard which is actually a former
convent and we are disguising it with a
lot of warnings and a lot of ground
cover on the floor and it's supposed to
be a really shocking place where Cersei
encounters the poverty that she has
managed to ignore for most of her time
living in King's Landing I'm standing
there looking butch in my chill I do a
lot of that no that's it no that's it I
fight giggle I sound like tingle down so
I can't actually move I'm not allowed to
move out this
[Music]
for right now we are in a town called
Asuna and it has this beautiful old bull
ring and it's a National Monument as
well when we walked into this bullring
it was just you know the place they were
looking for
hey youtubers is Charlie so they just
aired Game of Thrones day-in-the-life
it's just a behind-the-scenes special
for one day of filming on Game of
Thrones across their three film units
this is probably my favorite thing that
the show has done to promote itself I
don't consider myself a filmmaker but
the filmmaking process fascinates me
just as much as the actual episodes
there weren't any actual spoilers they
filmed around some scenes being filmed
but in a very non spoilery way like
there's a scene with Cersei in the high
Sparrow really that like the three big
locations that we see the three big
places they focus on are one the new
high Sparrow set that's in King's
Landing Jonathan Pryce is character the
high Sparrow just has like his own
little area where a lot of his scenes
are gonna take place if you're not
familiar with the sparrows I actually
did a video just just about the high
Sparrow himself so I add a link in the
description for that if you want to
learn more we also see the water gardens
in Spain which is actually probably the
most beautiful looking said that'll be
like the primary Dorne location so
whenever we get house Martell scenes we
get like Prince Doran the sand snakes
most of it is gonna be in and around the
water gardens they filmed in this 13th
century palace so it's really funny
usually filming in places like that is
almost impossible just because there are
a lot of rules
the caretakers just want to make sure
that the film crew doesn't trash
whatever historical monument that
they're filming at it'd be like inviting
your friends over to make a YouTube
video your house like you wouldn't want
them breaking your stuff either
then they featured the Corey set which
has been used for a lot of stuff before
like they use it for the Battle of
Blackwater for the King's Landing set
they've used it as a stand-in for Castle
black and now it's gonna be hard home I
think the two most fun things about the
special though we're learning that it
took them three weeks to film the Battle
of hardhome and des max Pitt
it didn't take him three weeks to film
des max Pitt there's gonna be a lot of
stuff there please use spoiler tags if
you have read books four and five
sometimes you forget that it takes an
army to film Game of Thrones it's like
an army behind the army that you see on
screen the way they film is a little bit
different from a lot of other TV shows
to most TV shows have a main unit in a
secondary unit when they shoot small
scenes but Game of Thrones they only do
ten episodes so they're able to film
several episodes at the same time it's
probably one of the reasons why they
only do ten episodes so they can spend
more money on production that's usually
where most of the budget goes not to
effects just literally like hiring the
army of people that it takes to film an
episode so they were to do like 13
episodes 16 episodes a year it would be
vastly different they would be able to
spend nearly
much money so either take them longer to
film or they wouldn't be able to do as
many locations here's my big question
for you guys
obviously we haven't read winter winter
or book seven yet dream of spring but is
there like a new location that you would
want Game of Thrones to go film at I
think maybe like the Chinese imperial
city that would be really interesting I
don't think that there's been a whole
lot of sets that look like they would be
Chinese in the story so far so when we
want to see where George R Martin takes
the story you have to remember that even
though they're filming a lot of
different cities like Braavos Dorne they
still don't go to too many places Spain
was really like the one new place that
they went to to film but regardless of
where scenes take place in the world of
Game of Thrones like on the map they
film a lot of stuff in the same places
like Croatia Ireland and Spain I only
did just where do they film all the
stuff in the north so there is a new
round of the giveaway right now all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment it's just a $20
Amazon gift card there's a couple extra
videos that I have to do the next couple
days so in case I don't get to a Game of
Thrones Q&A the giveaway will just be
open until I post my next game of
Thrones video so no worries for those
that are asking there isn't anything on
the schedule for HBO Game of Thrones in
March but they will do something to
promote the show like now that we're
getting closer there'll be more trailers
there'll be more footage don't worry
everybody get hype okay so why you guys
waiting for more Game of Thrones to come
you can click here to watch the full
special it's like the full 28 minute
special and you can click here to watch
the trailer again thank you so much
watching so let's all high-five I'll see
you guys tonight
you